hey yeah what's up party people welcome
to the honest trailer commentary for
terminator door yeah oh oh here oh it's
really dark we're gonna be talking about
our thought process behind the trailer
some deleted scenes responding to
questions and comments from viewers like
you a little tease for next week's on
estrella that's exciting yeah I'm here
dan hello here with lon
hey Danielle is working and Joe is that
town yeah that should be enough to take
on and take down this travesty in a
meeting it's this is a film that my
perspective on this film and why I think
maybe I was more lenient or positive ID
is Terminator Genisys might be my least
favorite movie mmm ever made Wow that's
bold
in modern like studio filmmaking out of
that process like not an experimental
weird potentially upsetting film Tamara
jazz this was so just half-assed in
every choice made to me was the wrong
choice and the acting was wooden and
yeah we're not talking about that you
can see other videos for us about
Genesis but I do think we should talk
about relaunching Skynet as an app that
merits discussion they you can tell that
they were working on it for years before
it got me yeah is like the killer
feature of Skynet or whatever Genesis
that made everyone update it was like it
syncs your email and your files what do
you guys think about dork Freight I
think it is the best Terminator sequel
by default but the reason I think is the
best Terminator sequel is that I think
it is a well staged well acted well shot
pretty exciting action movie that is the
most offensive Terminator movie
it's a sense of like I liked every
aspect about this film except the fact
that I think it completely insults
everything about the franchise to sequel
just to clarify before they beat us up I
think it's I think yes obviously just a
sequel to Terminator 2 thank you that
has yet been made yeah I almost feel
like terminator eternity to have merged
into one film the terminators let's say
I've been trying to make sequels how
towards your freight long I mean I
there's a couple cool action scenes in
this movie I think my two main gripes
are the thing in the beginning that
really upsets the car like it sucks but
it's not one of my main gripe my two
makers are it's very much like redoing
t2 just kind of changing some
superficial details but otherwise the
storytelling is is very similar and I'm
tired of gooey goo based oil black nano
villains where it's just like they're
just like melty liquid guys and it
always looks the same like black sludge
II stuff good strong anti goo stands
does any better we've seen it a bunch of
I think that there's goo potential
because like you can do anything with a
goo and what they do is in this one he
split in two he went from two to goo and
then he also has GUI knife hands but I
think there's so many other things arms
and blades and use them to like poke
holes become some like her if ik like
penny wise made of knives demon thing
and then hunt somebody threw a punch
like a monster we haven't tried that it
would probably be like more effective
than just being like a goo a cop with a
knife hand that's really why a on a
terminator level I was so not happy with
this movie I'm from a mythology
standpoint because I didn't I did not
jump off board at the beginning of the
movie she okay you killed John Connor at
the beginning of the movie you
completely invalidate Terminator 2
I was like okay like that's a bold move
and you know what I respect it but where
do we go from here and the answer was we
just remake Terminator 2 again
yeah and that's I was like no you can't
do something just to do that and then
basically like the use is an easy reboot
switch and that's like I'm not against
huge ramifications things to mythology
yeah if it's in service of something
great but they did the thing that I also
didn't like in the Halloween movie which
was they sort of brought everyone back
in on this premise of like we're wiping
away the past and we are gonna get rid
of all this messy crazy mythology and
we're bringing the original stars back
and it's it's like the final showdown
like this is the sequel that you've been
waiting for and I think both movies were
just cheap setups to pump out more
sequels it's like if you're gonna do
this thing of the resets and the
bringing people back that's great but do
something interesting don't just make it
a another song tree to another sequel
factory because it's like now you've
wasted that around - that's what I feel
like it's just it's it's cynical it's
like let's just we're gonna pretend like
we're doing taking this crazy left turn
but actually we're just basically read
bits of greatest hits we're gonna bring
back the dialogue you remember the
setups you remember we're not gonna
resolve anything
no and set this up as a new platform -
yeah like basically relaunch the series
and do it all over again actually it's
frustrating as a viewer yes you're doing
it's like the most the most callous
cynical version of it in this one is
it's not Skynet anymore it's legion
Legion it's like oh what's different
about it yeah nothing is different about
it we just changed the name it's like
well you're gonna change you could
change everything about it maybe it's
not even an AI anymore it's something
different like that's the other thing is
like okay it's not Skynet it's legion
it's something completely different
that made the exact same killing robots
that are also called terminator that
also have skeletons that also use time
travel that also is ready for they
changed the naming system they didn't
change anything yeah it's the same stuff
well there is no
fate but what we make for ourselves
unless you are in one of these movies
because anything's gonna happen so let's
watch our eyes trailer for terminator a
dork freak I'm referencing that episode
of wife swap just in case no wife's well
that famous episode I believe it's
called the god warrior I didn't know it
you were referencing I've just been
playing on three let you down
salvation left you bored and Genesis had
you wondering what you've done to
deserve this this much that the Holy
kind of like Terminator 3 I liked the
ending of Terminator I liked the deleted
scene were like clever that's the only
follow-up to teaching that has a clever
twist on the Terminator mythology I
think I agree I was actually very
surprised at the end of Terminator 3 and
I respected what they did yeah like oh
is that when the Judgment Day happy they
think they're gonna stop Skynet
potentially are just getting to the
bunker so they can survive so the I
Connor can become the leader
unfortunately in the middle of it yet
talk to the hand Joe yeah it was really
goofy it's got some weak moments but
like the whole like at the cemetery and
then the chase like that's really cool
there's some good stuff there give it a
read watch let's move let's keep going
decent Terminator movie only now no one
gives us you know you think out of all
the franchises this one would have a
better sense of timing yeah
Terminator dark fate do you like the
first two terminators what if they did
that again but this time lost I'll go
back to that side of the walking out of
the ocean like that with their guns out
yeah just the the future war that
they're in it seems like it's being
fought by two idiots generals both on
the human side and the robot side we're
like again you could be anything
liquid metal you make it anything and
they just remake the human body the
gradual out of balance human body and
give it to gently
it's a slowly walk at the ocean you
could just make its hands the gun you
don't have to give it little they're
fighting like a like a swarm of drones
oh and and guys like this and stuff like
that again just like infantry just give
them a gun and have running well yeah I
had a weapon based complaint that did
not make it into this which is that if
you're watching this spoilers but the
enhanced human has insight of her her
power source is a terminator kill own
that's one of our tags that we didn't
know it is what if they did that again
but this time Kyle Reese was a girl John
Connor was a girl and everything else
was the same from the characters to the
action
I'll be back
sorta come with me if you want to live
come with me if you want them sit down
is it mehico' how do you not work hasta
LaVista this one it was right there
forget em I waited the last three films
and done and scrapped in for a story
that picks up a few years after t2 then
instantly makes that whole movie
pointless again it's like I'm not
against bold I feel like the Jerry
Seinfeld thing when it's just like when
these thinks that his dentist converted
to Judaism for the jokes yeah and the
guy is like oh so defends you as a Jew
he's like no it offends me as a comedian
I'm not offended just as a person I'm
offended as a terminator fan because
they did something that drastic in
service of the most predictable reboot
formula you could possibly imagine like
if you're gonna do something like that
then do something interesting with the
story like do something different or
unexpected like I like to Linda Hamilton
in this movie and I like to Sarah Connor
and I like this version of her where she
can't get over it and she's great and I
even liked that they did with our
Swardson ager and the whole idea of like
what is determined because we never
really seen what does it Terminator do
after it does what it's supposed to do
yeah they don't go back forward they
don't go back forward in time so like
that I that like I enjoy that aspect of
it but like everything else around it
was just a complete remake of the second
movie it's like you have a little you
have an open for the first time ever you
blow John Connor away you have an open
open roadmap to do whatever you want
yeah and instead they're just like yeah
we're just gonna remake the second one
it's like yeah really it's a weird call
cuz it's so clearly shock value you
could just explain like you could have
Linda Hamilton show up his old Sarah
Connor and explain what happened to John
it doesn't have to be we see him being
murdered like it could be like he's off
doing these fighting terminators in
Sweden there what do you know
you'd have to figure like at the end of
Terminator 2 after what they've been
through like they would be less chill
still like they wouldn't be like let's
go on spring break
shelf barge John probably still be off
the grid like Sammy Hagar is like Cabo
Wabo because you want us to have that
shock moment of oh my god they killed
Eddie furlong bastards don't have
anything to do with it's just there and
then it's over there - Reid grizzle
Sarah Connor but I'm saying she would
never have bun grizzled there's no
Unger's we got it let's keep going that
off you're in for a back-to-basics
Terminator picture where law enforcement
doesn't die
the Krannert traditions do the future I
appreciated that because that was my
biggest issue with Genesis is that they
really tried to break down the rules of
time travel
what terminators couldn't couldn't do
gonna burp thank you
they just got so in the weeds and they
gave a lot of that expository dialogue
to Arnold yeah and this one were they're
like you know what I'm doing future
stuff yes I don't care how your real
advantage in a Kyle Reese character is
somebody from the future who can explain
things as a human would allow me to
explain few movies now we've only had
robots traveling back and so yeah you've
been giving a lot of dialogue to a robot
they're not doing because they're a
robot yeah advantage of putting a Grace
character so I'm fine with every time
travel movie doing something to that
effect we like doing future [ __ ] did we
put the chip bag thing as one of the
tags or no no if we did Sarah Connor
became your crazy aunt who keeps her
phone in a tip bag that wouldn't work
Connor would know that the potato chip
bag
keep your phone in a character that she
would even believe that would work okay
yeah she's been trained in yeah I feel
like she would just have like a Nokia
phone like a brick phone anyways it
wouldn't be Kiko you doing shooters and
the guns don't do much of anything
who's that Genesis amid the acid rain
trend okay that was my plan yeah Linda
Hamilton returns as Sarah Carla captures
the terminus press every two years cycle
of reboots term writer drops out
so I destroy two years later same thing
but she's not the only badass with let
me speak to your manager hair there's
grace and enhanced human with a couple
of minutes of super strength in her
before she gets white girl wasted yeah
again this is an odd thing of just like
alright we're gonna send you back to
protect the future savior of humanity
and you will be effective for up to two
minutes of fighting completely disabled
and helpless I'm like relying on like
rare prescription drugs like not even
have her be able to be refueled by like
a turkey legs down over a plate of
Thanksgiving mini-boss and you have to
get you know restock your energy it's a
total video game trope fair enough just
have it be something she can easily
obtain she's got a had plutonium like
it's back to the future it's nothing but
I this movie inadvertently makes the
future not as much of a dystopia as they
think it is because this movie takes
place present day right like 2019 2018
something like that and the she sent
back from the 2040s believes that means
in the next 20 years we crack like human
robot augmentation time-travel we got
time-travel you next intelligence and
time travel both writer
well I almost there put on a terminator
nerd glasses the concept of time travel
was never cracked by humanity it was in
fact the machines
opted the machines when they invaded the
Skynet's headquarters in the final
battle sent Terminator John Kyle Reese
back okay I protect Sarah Connor it
seems like pretty commonplace in this
timeline it seems like you can send
whoever back apparently they had an
assembly line of terminate they were
sending back in future Skynet is a thing
that is like in every Terminator movie
prior to this one they kind of they kind
of do away with this on Sarah Connor
Chronicles so we'll put that aside but
it's it's very hard to get your hands on
the time-travel equipment we can only
ever send one the understanding is
always been like we could only ever send
one person back yeah it's very specific
and we can only do this one and then I
guess they would kind of abandon that
now because the idea was that they were
sending a bunch of terminators on John
Connor all around the world just at
least one could get lucky
mm-hmm which is kind of kind of breaks
terminator a little bit like if you
could just an infinite robots and
soldiers back yeah why not send one back
to like the 1880s take over the country
and they could shoot the first fish to
crawl on land and problem
but then wouldn't you manatee do not
grow to then create Skynet in the first
place Yeah right get the sweet spot you
gotta wait until that's to I guess they
have to prove they can't prevent their
own creation yeah creation is prevented
in every movie right and they still keep
well we always have explored the idea
that even if the Connors or whoever they
just delay we don't I don't know if it
goes the other way like if they had
managed to kill off every Raziel like if
they killed the Connors and then Danny
and like every resistance fighter leader
like so the whole time-travel thing is
pointless because you're just
whack-a-mole like yeah you stop one and
then another hero will rise maybe it's a
commentary on you know Middle East
policy another drum so humanity is
al-qaeda okay
lilamon unlikely alliance with the t800
model who killed John Connor then used
his newfound free will to become a
celibate texan drape salesman our
relationship is not physical hit the
drapes weird flex but all right all to
protect dad photos abilities resistance
thanks to her powerful message robots
bad you should be fighting the machines
Oh for real Wow never thought of that d
brother shark that was particularly dumb
that they the scene they chose to show
to reveal that she was the resistance
leader in this alternate timeline not
John Connor was they were accosting
grace about to stab her and kill her for
the food in her backpack yes and Danny
shows a unarmed and just like kind of
wrestles one of them to a standstill it
was like forget food guns down everyone
guns down you're still starving and you
need the food in that banitsa go to yeah
we didn't need that scene we we saw that
scene already it's in Terminator
Salvation we see the scene where John
Connor saves young Kyle Reese and it's
almost exactly it plays out almost
identical yeah alright let's keep going
you should be fighting the machines Oh
for real Wow never thought of that - you
brought it up guess you're in charge
then
ready to run from the all-new t rev1980
model with the power to split itself
into and make itself a dude but like
terminus unthinking killing machine
won't hesitate to dramatically hesitate
and when this monster making nut punch
gets too close to a main character you
can bet he'll shove a real hard is a
serious trope yeah and before he kills
you
you can bet he'll disarm you with cold
calculating manners you bribed something
I think like that Arnold was also an
infiltration unit yes well Arnold was
built to be an entry look human get in
with other humans and then right and I
guess maybe I'm sure there's a timeline
explanation for it but like okay you're
going south of the border this is
probably the guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
massive massive like predator makes
sense running man he's so out of place
yes but the weird ones are always
everyday guy yes the idea of sequels
have retro actively made T to a little
silly yeah like they should all they
should all look like little lanky
scrappy young dudes or just like you
know 90s Los Angeles so as all of our
faves get old enjoy another installment
in the localization of pop culture where
a franchise film comes out that doesn't
dwell on the terrible sequels brings
back a grizzled ass-kicker gives them a
mean case of PTSD pairs that with a
young girl to hopefully take over from
here and has them do all the stuff you
like but just differently enough to eke
another 10 to 20 bucks out of you before
dementia sets in and every movie feels
new again I'll be back
we know we will actually be partners
Gooper trooper okay you know lot Carl
gone in 60 seconds and the American
healthcare system do you have a doctor's
prescription prescription Terminator
Jose they took her damn machines I
already try to wipe us out and now
they're taking our factory gigs have a
Luddite all right let's let's watch them
to lead at sea and see what else we said
and in a brand-new twist half of it is
in Mexico which is technically different
from setting in Noa technically story
protocol Danny Makai Danny California
The Amazing Race Kylie Reese augment of
a woman have you seen this ER God Lady
Stoneheart
granny Get Your Gun school senior wait
they gave Arnold a secret Latin ex
family seems a little on the nose my
back and my least favorite murder
Oh one Terminator to Benny Terminator to
work fate all right be my magazine take
our world fine but don't you dare take
our jerbs stupid machines robot bad all
right if enhanced humans run on a power
source that kills terminators from close
range when I just make weapons out of
that and skip the middleman yeah she has
a thing inside of her that when you stab
a terminator it not only takes out that
Terminator but also any Terminator near
it yeah and doesn't appear to cause any
physical damage to people and doesn't
appear to harm humans so like why not
just make guns that shoot those very
inefficient protection very yes no
mortal machine wrapped around something
that kills terminators instantly also if
she clearly has not watched Terminator 3
because it's the same move that that
Terminator does to kill the lady
Terminator at the end of that movie is
take out his nuclear fuel cell and stuff
in it but that was at least like an
a-bomb so like you can't just go around
shooting nuclear weapon right but that
was literally just like a thing that he
just shoot and determinated melts them
put it on a stick poke all right what do
y'all have to say about this dumb movie
with right how is this a decent
Terminator film where are the standards
for good movies just drooping every
drooping I compared this one to the
others and I think that this is I mean
decent terminator the standards for good
movies are just drooping every year
that's weak I think that's
they'd be driven yeah I think for me
decent Terminator film is you know I
think by default it's in the middle of
the pack for me like just because I
can't stand salvation or Genesis I think
it's clearly better than four and five I
think three is where you start to now
we're in a conversation
I prefer three but I could see how you
could give either one of those of the
past so let's that's upper 50% well
taken holistically I would take this
over three just because I feel like the
middle part is better I like the ending
of three that's a speed round question
like Terminator 3 Terminator 6 like oh
okay I think there's pluses and minuses
on each side four or five clearly below
this yeah so Jay Logan writes if the
resistance has access to reprogram T
eight hundreds like we've seen in two
different movies now why send back a
human who can't even use her super mode
without halfway killing herself so like
why not instead of grace why not send
back another arm another Arnold exists
apparently in this future Legion you
could say I guess you could defend that
by saying Legion doesn't have the
equivalent of a t800 that could be
reprogrammed they don't know how to
reprogram the the Rev whatever let's
think you send back and advanced okay
intensity but should be interesting
mariko true rights if you have a real
good time machine and go back to the
scripts origin what changes would you
make to increase dork fate success and
rejuvenate the franchise i liked if you
read the sense at a different way like
she means if you had a real good time
machine but you could really like if you
had a real good time machine
got a good times machine time machine
they would let me go back to change the
script of this movie though I'd keep the
set up I actually would I would I would
write I would say don't remake
Terminator 2 do something with Sarah
Connor and and Arnold and like their
current the legacy I would say take the
legacy characters and keep what you did
intact but come up with something new
for the new characters that makes this
yeah worth a different direction what
about this like could you have I don't
know I just I feel like I want Legion to
be different than Skynet if we're gonna
do the thing that Skynet is no more we
there's a different future now we're a
different humanity killing threat has
arisen I would say I don't have a great
idea but like something else not AI
building robots like not the same thing
yeah and I still think you bring in
Arnold and he that's how you that's your
Terminator connection so we've still got
a terminator on our side that's gonna
help us face this new threat I just
don't think you redo it's the same exact
threat again we've seen it five times
you got an opportunity a new future
threat has arisen okay
I would I would change it kind of go
back to its roots like I would make this
a lower budget horror action movie like
you know this came to James Cameron in a
nightmare this was a this was a literal
nightmare that he had that he wrote
Terminator 1 bit Terminator 2 but we're
making it in Mexico
oh my god I was fighting with the guy
who made Deadpool a bad dream he had
make it like a more nightmarish like you
have an enhanced human you got a
terminator chasing him or her and like
they gotta get to the time machine at
the top of the building right just dread
affiant a single location would be great
it's like then the threat is not this
terminators like the ultimate killing
machine it could be a more simple
terminator but it's like we can't get
away from it yeah that's the element
that's missing is like the
relentlessness that it's like you cannot
escape this thing and this one just
seemed kind of like an action movie
what's a chase it more like an alien
like like an alien here yeah exactly
so that would be the change more than
the t1000 the new one whatever the rav 9
just showed up in a plane it is more
epic than I expected it to be like it
yeah the finale plane crashes over
Hoover Dam the scale is impressive and
then there are a million questions and
comments about the Alan Raptor if you're
new and you've watched this far we hide
a Jurassic Park 3 raptor in every
episode says allen wrench now it's just
gonna raptor yeah because that's just
the head so we might hide a raptor
somewhere but it's I in my mind in my
hand it's the one he dreamed about yet
we just show full bodies we do it for
two reasons number one to entertain
ourselves and to to frustrate and
confuse you
yes mostly the samosa you directly do
and that's the honest trailers promise
we hope you enjoyed that we hope you
will come back next week where we are
we are digging in you know we'll have
everything we need for it to make a good
meal of this next movie and we'll be
back at this desk at this time thanks
for watching okay
[Music]
you